Whether you have an IQ of 50 or 150, we all feel intelligent, after all, no doubt minds
Smart people like Einstein, Tesla or Stephen Hawking helped form
The world we live in. Is it possible to genetically improve intelligence?
Our whole type?
DNA is the basic life symbol present in every living organism. This DNA consists of genes
Which in turn consists of 4 smaller parts called nuclear bases
Represented by the letters A, T, G and C. In humans, these rules are arranged at 3 billion pairs, which work primarily
As a blueprint for everything the cells of the body need
Literally, all you are - by the way you look and act - is defined
By regulating these four biological compounds
Scientists have been able to find links between the way genes are organized and some features
Which you offer - from your sex to the color of your eyes and even diseases that may develop
It was already a human genome project that first began analyzing and mapping all genes
In the human body. The initial project took more than a decade and $ 3 billion to complete
With teams all over the world working together. Today, with a much smaller team
The same can be achieved in a few days ... for only $ 4000
As sequenced genomes accumulate - whether they are from plants, microbes or humans
The more we compare the features we see abroad
With gene combinations, we find the inside. This is exactly what he hopes
Project Genome knowledge achieved
Using more than 2,000 people with more than 150 IQ, plans to deliver
More than 20,000 other subjects, researchers at the BGI Institute in China are looking for
Basically the genetic intelligence. In other words, they scan DNA for thousands
From smart people, to look for patterns you might be responsible for making smart
in the first place
Of course, this is a much more complicated task than looking for a satisfactory pattern, for example
Tay Sachs and Huntington's disease results in one genetic mutation
They are easily identified. Hair color and eye, on the other hand, depend on multiple genes interact
- However, with the correct analysis can be expected. But almost certainly personality like personality
Or intelligence is the result of thousands of genes that interact in unique ways
A pattern not yet discovered by scientists. The truth is they may not find one
But what happens if they do? I mean, future children may mean genius! With the advent of in vitro fertilization
You may be able to create multiple embryos and scan their DNA
Scientists will then be able to identify the most likely traits in each fetus
Based on their genes, allowing parents to choose the child they want
For example, this fetus has a 50% chance of being an exceptional musician, or this one has a 58% chance of having more than 150 IQ
In this way, the genetic information is not actually changed, but rather examined
We may actually be able to increase the intelligence of future generations
But what about you? Can you change your gene makeup to make you smarter and faster
Or stronger now?
Translation: شوان حميد Twitter: shwan_hamid @